I believe almost everyone should have a
podcast because having guests is a very
easy way to get content because it's an
easy way to create creative like you
have a guest they're doing the work you
ask them the seven cliche
questions God forbid the host has some
improv capabilities and can find the
moment I mean all of you live on social
the do you think's in your feed
half of it is podcast Clips I
think one of the biggest genres of
content creation is podcast while other
action is happening like I've been dying
for somebody to do a brushing your teeth
podcast like I want to double sink I
want the host brushing their teeth the
guests brushing their teeth that's the
show like brushing Through The Years or
I don't know cleaning up the day or like
literally I want a 24 Minute Podcast 137
my media company I've been dying to do
this we have a show now called serial
entrepreneur in the episode both people
are eating cereal like hot ones did this
right with hot wings right like I was on
it like I think there's 3 900 more hot
wings serial entrepreneurs to be made